- All right, well, I have to ask Tyra,
we're all living virtually these days,
so do you have one or two tips
for looking for looking fierce on Zoom?
I'm asking because I had to do my own
and then all of a sudden
I just didn't wear it
'cause I was like, look, I'm not you.
I don't do makeup, so.
- Yes, tips, okay.
You have to face the light.
So the window should
always be in front of you,
not behind you.
So many people have it behind them
and then they're back
lit like a silhouette.
Light in front of you.
Also, make sure that your
computer phone, iPad,
whatever it is that you're
using is at eye level.
So if you have to put five books
and then place that device on top of it,
do it so that it's eye level
so that we're not looking
up under you like that.
And then the last thing is I
know Zoom has a little feature
called touch up my appearance.
- What?
- Keep it on at all times.
- Yes.
It's like a retouch. You
don't know about that, Kelly?
- Oh my gosh.
I'm like looking on no
makeup on television
for my whole summer
series, just acne and all.
- Touch up appearance button.
- Well now it doesn't matter, Tyra
'cause I'm back in studio.
Oh my God, I had no idea
there was a touch up.
Well, y'all got the real real,
it was the sweaty, glisten, wow.
- That's why they love you so much though
'cause you gotta keep it real sometimes.
- Well, I'm an idiot.
I'd totally use that.
Like I'm not that real.
What was your go to to stay at home outfit
'cause I was all like half
athleisure and then a nice top.
Nobody can ever see the bottom half of me.
- Mine was I collect robes for some reason
and so people would be like, oh my God,
that top is fantastic
and I'm like, thank you.
It was just different robes.
- No one can see it.